is there like a framework so one of the
companies that uh i know because we were
an investor in it and still have a
little bit of public stock is coinbase
and at one point i think it was trading
at like one times basically revenue uh
plus their cash right so uh you look at
something like that and you're like man
you know maybe it could go down more but
like that sounds like a pretty good you
know multiple based on historical comps
like do you have some framework where
you're like okay if a company that has a
certain growth rate hits x it's
basically like a screaming buy
opportunity and we look to to deploy
capital
well the thing that's tricky about
i i agree that by historical standards
certainly coinbase now seems cheap the
the hard thing about
valuing a company like coinbase is
obviously it's totally derivative of
what's happening in the crypto world you
use a different color yeah yeah so if
there's like a crypto crash it's like
well then what's coinbase so but like
sas companies for example these are
strong companies where
you know you look at their amount of ar
these are this is these are b2b
subscription businesses you want to look
at their net dollar attention you know
good for a public company usually starts
around 120 so on january 1st they're
typically starting with 120 of last
year's revenue just from their existing
customers
and then they're going to be stacking
new courts on top of that due to new
sales
we think those are very attractive
businesses they also tend to be more
insulated in a recession because they're
b2b not b2c and it's usually the
consumer who gets impacted first in a
recession there's a number of like very
fast-growing sas public sas companies
that are doing you know a billion ish
in revenue growing
forty percent year-over-year
like eighty percent growth seventy
eighty percent gross margins really high
gross margin businesses
these are like fun you know with very
strong franchises big moats at this
point
those are i think attractive companies
to own for the long term um
now
you know if you were in one of those
stocks and it's gone down 80 the hard
part is you know it's gonna take a long
time for them to grow into their old
valuations um
if you can buy now you're obviously the
entry price is much more attractive
for founders same exact problem right so
hey if you went out you raised money to
35 times uh multiple people hundred
times or a hundred times yeah whatever
whatever the numbers were a lot of it's
just undisciplined investing some of it
was just hey i felt fomo i have a big
fund i have to deploy the capital uh
what do you do there if you're the
founder who basically has this huge
thing i guess there's kind of two two
components one is like how do you ensure
that your investors end up coming out on
top right and do you just try to grow
into the valuation as quickly as you can
and then two is like how do you take
care of the employees who now maybe
their options are underwater or whatever
on that like how do you kind of
mentor founders in that situation yeah
so here's the good news if you're an
early stage startup is if you're a
public company for example and you're
growing 20 year-over-year and
you your value's gone down to 80 because
of this correction
uh you have to basically now grow 5x
what's that like 500 to get back to
where you were growing 20 a year like
that's gonna take you forever
however let's say that you are a startup
that's tripling your over a year and
there's like quite a few of those right
you raised 100 times last year well in
just one year it's going to be about 30
30 times 33 times because you've now
tripled your arr and the year after that
if you triple again you're going to be
at roughly 10 times arr and now you're
starting to look pretty cheap
so
you so it's much easier to grow into
what was perhaps an inflated evaluation
last year as an early stage company
that's roughly tripling or even say
growing two and a half times year over
year what you want to make sure of is
that you give yourself the time
because where you don't want to be is
needing to fundraise every 12 to 18
months like people are doing during the
frothy times you want to be in a
position where you don't have to raise
for two two and a half three years and
now you actually have the time to go
into your evaluation um you won't get as
big an up round
as you thought you're going to but
you have the chance if you grow
you know six to 10 times over two year
period to now get an up round
i want to ask you a couple of uh
scenario-based kind of just tactical
things that i've heard founders ask me
or talk about when i've been at dinners
or
kind of gatherings the first is uh if
you want to cut your burn how do you
evaluate uh cost and if you center on
okay i'm gonna have to cut staff like
who do you cut do you cut your high
salaries do you cut the people who you
think are the least productive do you
cut the people you don't like like you
know like what like what is the tactical
way to actually evaluate hey i have to
cut you know i caught my uh head count
by 30 like who do i cut
yeah i think so i think first of all you
have to figure out how much you need to
cut and one thing you need to do is ask
the question am i capable of fundraising
in the current environment because
fundraising right now is very tough but
not impossible if you have great metrics
in the presentation that you mentioned
that we just sort of published
we have a slide that defines what good
looks like what sorry what great looks
like what good looks like and then what
batter we call a danger zone looks like
and what we've said is look if you have
all great metrics there's like five main
ones it's you know it's it's your ar
growth rate and a dollar retention
capital efficiency stuff like that
if it's all great you're gonna be able
to raise i would still be
cautious how you spend but it's not like
you know you're not gonna be able to
raise
if you're merely in the good column
you might have trouble if you're great
on three variables and good on two
you'll probably be able to raise if you
have any danger zone variables you
probably will not be able to raise
so the first thing you have to do is
assess do you have any danger zones do
you really think you're able to raise
and then the question it so let's say
that you
most orbs have some problem they need to
fix it could be a gross margin problem
could be an excess burn problem
could be a growth problem but if they're
in the danger zone you you now know that
i'm not going to raise when i run out of
money i'm dead
so i need to be able to make this money
last long enough to fix my problems to
get out of the danger zone and into good
to great metrics
so then the question is well how long do
you need to do that and in my experience
it takes
you know two years
you know minimum really to fix big
problems in a business it's hard right
doing startups is hard and you need to
give yourself the luxury of time to fix
those problems
the other thing you have to remember is
when you think about how much time you
need
if you give yourself two years runway
you haven't because
you got to go out and fundraise six
months nine months before you run out of
money so if you say i'm i have two years
of runway you've really only given
yourself
five maybe six quarters to make
effective changes in the business and
you know people want to see vcs want to
see that after you've made the changes
that they're working
so you know this is why we say give
yourself two and a half years so you
have two years to work on the business
then you can go fundraise and if you can
give yourself three so much the better
um you just don't know what market
conditions are going to be like when and
you don't want your company to go out of
business because of something that's
happening in the macri you know economic
environment
when when you think about um
the founder who could raise many other
than good maybe they're in the great uh
how much of this is like just go get the
money and the economic kind of structure
of the deal is less important than
actually getting the money versus uh you
guys advise founders to still hold on to
you know do good fundraising deals don't
take down rounds and um uh kind of what
is the weight of importance between
money maybe versus terms of the deal at
this point i think you want to get the
money um you don't mess around is my
view on this um look i
i've always believed that the market
sets the price and
it's better not to like monkey around
with that don't try to do tricks or
whatever it's like look just run an
efficient process get all of your
materials together go out to enough
firms
and then whatever the price is that's
the price i mean
we're all price takers in this market i
mean vcs are price takers too people
always think that somehow when i give
this like bad news that i'm like talking
my books and trying to drive down prices
i don't set the prices you know what
happens is a bunch of different firms
proffer term sheets or not and then you
kind of it shakes out where it shakes
out and then founders hear from other
founders who've gone through a process
recently and they hear oh like prices
aren't 100 times anymore like last year
they're 20 times you know
so word gets out the price levels adjust
and so vcs like our philosophy is we
just choose the deals we want to be in
and then we try to pay the prevailing
prices
and you know last year prices were high
this year they're lower but we just paid
the prevailing prices i would urge
founders to have that mentality as well
which is look you're just out there
raising this money because you need this
money
to survive and to grow your business
like
you know making deals with vcs is not
the point of your business it's just
something you do because you want to
fund it so go out there raise the money
you need run a tight process
run a good process
and where the valuation shakes out it
shakes out um and by the way if that
means a down round then so be it i mean
look i don't think there's a
public company on earth no matter how
good amazon tesla
you know microsoft so forth that hasn't
had huge down days in the stock market
it hasn't all been one way up but yet
founders always think that well i've got
to get like a huge up around it's like
sometimes the world doesn't work that
way yeah um a founder calls you says
david how do i run an efficient
fundraising process in this environment
is it get the materials in a data room
go out to 50 firms just set up zooms
back to back to back and you know see
where term sheets come in or
is it something more complicated no i
think that's basically it i mean maybe
not 50 maybe start with 10
but yeah like get all of your materials
together um you know it's you know what
questions you're gonna get asked you
know
what materials you're gonna need i don't
understand why founders have fundraising
conversations without getting all their
materials together first you know as
soon as they think oh it's not well i'm
just having coffee with a vc or whatever
no it's like look any conversation with
vc is a fundraising conversation sorry
it's the way it is
so get all your [ __ ] together we're not
getting to know each other
well that matters too but it's but it's
still a fundraising conversation like
there's no point going out and having
those conversations if you don't have
your materials together so get them
together create your data room
um have all the metrics ready
again you know in the sas world it's
very obvious what you're gonna be asked
and
so if we start stumping you
with questions that like it just shows
you're disorganized so
it's an easy way to put your best foot
forward as a founder is just get all
your stuff together and then you
probably are going to need to create a
longer list
than usual of firms to go talk to
um and you can do it in in waves um
sometimes you'll get some feedback on
the first set of pitches you did and
then you can adjust your deck sometimes
you'll hear the same concern over and
over again you might want to add a slide
to address it do you tell founders go to
the best firms first or maybe the firms
that they're not
as excited about getting so they get the
feedback and then go to the best firms
um
yeah i think you just want to go to the
list of firms that you think are the
best fit for your business
and some of them are more prestigious
names than others but i wouldn't stress
too much about that in this environment
yeah yeah
and you know
just go to the the vcs who've expressed
the most interest in your type of
business
another topic that is become way more
popular than i ever thought it would is
uh founder secondaries and uh one i
guess just like what's your perspective
from the investor seat but also having
built businesses uh when founders should
take secondaries or when it's a red flag
that they're taking secondaries and kind
of how to structure them and then two is
uh founders now who have taken
secondaries have a pot of money and most
founders didn't have a pot of money
before now they do and they're asking
themselves like am i a vc now should i
just go angel invest in all my friends
companies should i just stick in the s p
500 and you know forget about it and go
work on my company like how do you
advise founders there yeah so on on
founders taking secondaries um
i think that
it's so the way secondary started you
know way back when is that you would
have a company
that was doing well that maybe got an
acquisition offer
and there's a feeling on the board
especially on the part of vcs that this
company could be much bigger if they
just kept going but the founder had all
their eggs in one basket and would be
very tempted to take this offer and so
creating liquidity for partial liquidity
for a founder was a great way to align
everyone to go for the big long term win
and so i'm very supportive of that idea
and you know i've been a founder i've
had all my eggs in my basket it's nice
if you can
if you've earned the right to take some
secondary because you've created a great
business
and you want to take a few chips off the
table then go for a bigger win um
is that like five percent of your
position or like fifty percent like how
do you think that would be way too much
okay you know i think
what i've seen is founders taking a few
percent you know off the table that kind
of idea okay um you know if you see 50
it's like we'll just sell the whole
company i mean that just
um but i think what happened is that in
the boom times you started seeing
secondaries become almost a matter of
course because there was so much funding
that was trying to get into companies
and look i think it became acceptable as
well in an environment in which
companies were potentially overfunded
and investors were trying to get to a
certain ownership level that they're
like hey can we buy some secondary from
the founders and i don't really have a
problem with that either but where i
would
you know caution is
in a much more difficult fundraising
environment it's irresponsible for
founders to be seeking to take chips off
the table when that money could be going
into the corporate treasury in other
words into primary in the company and if
there's any concern about the company
not being adequately funded enough and
the founders seeking to put money in
their own pocket that's a conflict of
interest
and you know it's not in keeping with
their duty
of loyalty to the company put the
company first so i think in the current
environment a founder seeking to take
chips off the table would be an
incredibly negative signal and would
probably sabotage your funding round so
i would not do that if somehow you're
one of the few companies in this
environment in which people are
literally throwing more money at you
than you could possibly need
and you and the board decide together
like look this is more money than we
need
then maybe the founder could take chips
off the table but i wouldn't go seeking
to do that in this environment yeah i
think it makes complete sense uh and
then for those who either already have
or are in the fortunate position where
they've built such a great business that
people are throwing money at them uh
what's been your advice to people in
terms of hey you're a founder you now
have a pot of money whether it's a
million dollars or more um you know
bigger sums
put an s p
angel invest set it in cash uh
give it to a fund manager like what do
you say yeah what i would say so i think
typically what makes sense for
a lot of people like founders is to have
kind of a barbell strategy so you've
already got most of your net worth is
tied up in the form of equity in this
highly risky startup you know let's say
over here on the distribution so the
question is what do you do with the rest
of the money and
i think what probably makes sense is to
the barbell is you put that money in the
safest thing possible basically because
you already have so much exposure
to to market uncertainty and risk
through the bulk of your net worth which
is in your company
and you want to avoid like
excessive correlation to like let's say
a
like a depression or a recession or
something like that i mean think about
what would happened
let's say that you were a founder who
did a big secondary last year
and you took all that money and you put
it in crypto or you put it in the nasdaq
well now you're down 50 you know
and you already had enough exposure
to start up risk
and sort of macroeconomic risk through
your company so i would i would advocate
for a barbell strategy